should ukraine declare its neutrality as
a way to stop the war with fighting into
a fourth week the kremlin is considering
the neutral status compromise to stop
its attacks will the ukrainians
surrender to the pressure from moscow
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum it's been three weeks
since russia launched this invasion of
ukraine ukraine cities are being
bombarded from land sea and air
as the destruction worsens the warring
sides are discussing a ceasefire both
sides are warning of significant
differences but one possibility is
ukraine declaring its neutrality like
sweden or austria and the ukrainians
renouncing their ambitions to join nato
as well as promising not to host foreign
military bases or weapons in exchange
ukraine would get protection from allies
such as the u.s britain and turkey so
far ukraine's leaders have rejected
russia's
proposals ukraine is now in a direct
state of war with russia as a result the
model can only be ukrainian and only on
legally verified security guarantees
the problems which are fundamental for
russia for our future of ukraine's
neutrality ukraine's demilitarization
and denusification
we were and we are ready to discuss the
talks our country did its best to
organize and hold these talks
understanding that every possibility is
to save people but what we see time and
again is that the key regime which was
assigned by its western masters to
create an anti-russian offensive is
indifferent to the fate of the ukrainian
people
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
first let's look at the timeline of
tensions between russia and ukraine
ukraine was part of the soviet union
until its collapse in 1991. since
gaining independence ukrainians have
suffered political upheaval at home and
tension with russia
in 1994 ukraine gave up its nuclear
arsenal in exchange for a commitment
from russia to respect its independence
and sovereignty
moscow has since been concerned with
keeping ukraine from joining the nato
military alliance
mass protests eight years ago toppled
president viktor yanukovych that
happened after he refused to sign a
trade deal with european union as he
sought closer ties with moscow
russia's armed forces responded by
annexing the crimean peninsula and
backing a separatist rebellion in
eastern ukraine
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests joining us from outside of
kiev and ukraine peter zamayev executive
director of the eurasia democracy
initiative that's a non-profit
organization which promotes democracy
and rule of law in former communist
countries
from russia's capital moscow pavel
felgenhauer defense and military analyst
for novia gazeta newspaper
and from germany's capital berlin
andreas umland analyst at the stockholm
center for eastern european studies
that's part of the swedish institute of
international affairs
thanks so much to you all for joining us
we appreciate your time today on inside
story peter let me start with you today
with all that you are seeing and
experiencing on the ground there in
ukraine when you hear
that these negotiations are going on uh
that russia wants to see ukraine declare
its neutrality do you think
that that is something that is actually
feasible right now
well uh so far going by the track record
of the way the russians have
communicated their intentions i would
not
uh you know hold my breath you know in
the weeks running up to russia's
invasion on february 24th
we heard assurances almost on a daily
basis that russia had no intention of
invading ukraine then a few days before
the actual invasion uh russia announced
that it was uh withdrawing troops from
ukraine's borders which never happened
obviously uh
and and then we were like
fully in uh the war situation
with russia you know
having unleashed its uh terror
against all of ukraine's territory
pretty much what i'm seeing right now is
uh you know um
i i suspect maybe a smokescreen smoke
screen uh for uh
russia's real intention and that is to
regroup to try to uh
you know restore its uh morale of its
fighting troops because it's reported to
be very low uh and to try to storm kiev
uh a second time it's simply uh
not feasible for me right now to imagine
a vladimir putin would be withdrawing
his troops and then claiming the already
existing status quo in ukraine is a
victory you know there's a sunk cost
fallacy where you know having expended
this much blood and treasure vladimir
putin would probably think of that kind
of scenario as tantamount to his
political or even physical death so i'm
skeptical
even though i do believe that eventually
some sort of a compromise diplomatically
must be found in order for this to stop
andreas it's being reported that ukraine
and russia are making progress on some
type of potential ceasefire do you think
that this is achievable
it will depend on the assessment of the
so-called correlation of forces in
moscow
how
moscow will
assess the continuing costs and risks of
this confrontation with ukraine and also
the associated costs and risks in
for its economy because of sanctions
that is very difficult to say how this
assessment
goes but it also clearly depends on
western measures on the degree of
sanctions the degree of military support
for ukraine
but i would not exclude that at some
point maybe not now we may come to this
point and then
the exact formulation of this neutrality
idea could come to the fore the problem
here of ukraine is
not so much russia actually but is
rather the west
in that
ukraine has since 2008 an official
membership perspective
from nato but it has not advanced since
then through this membership uh
it has not received the membership
action plan it has entered a few
additional programs of nato but um in
substance nothing has actually happened
and that will probably continue this
situation and under the impression of um
of this sad story um yes uh yeltsin i'm
already saying zelinski has recently
indicated that he may actually be ready
to negotiate this uh this issue about
neutrality about not any longer entering
nato but then i think ukraine will try
to get some other mutual aid agreement
from
um
from the west that clearly go beyond the
budapest memorandum of 1994
it will want some sort of
real security assurances real security
guarantees
uh that go beyond the sort of monogamy
pact from 1994. pavel when russia
demands that ukraine declare neutrality
what exactly does that mean what does
that mean
for president putin what would he like
to see
uh well
the kremlin has explained that russia is
not so much seeking ukrainian neutrality
since ukraine is already right now a
neutral country
officially
but that
russia wants ironclad guarantees that
ukraine will never become a nato member
or
maybe more importantly that ukraine
no weapons of any sorts can appear on
ukrainian territory that could
potentially threaten russia because the
kremlin and the russian president said
they can be not member of nato doesn't
matter they can have any way some
american missiles or something these
american presumed missiles that right
now are not really in existence but may
appear several in several years or
something are a very important point for
president putin personally and for the
kremlin that seemed that they could be
deployed in ukraine and can hit targets
in the moscow area very swiftly without
saying the russian leader should be
unable to become airborne or hide in a
bunker or something so that's what right
now russia wants it wants rather ukraine
to be under russian
sort of control and security matters
that russia would have a decisive voice
there and also of course very important
for russia is that the new ukrainian
government or the old ukrainian
government recognize that crimea is a
part of russia recognize the
independence of these small state goods
in the donbas
and the general once
russia wants to see ukraine as a
decentralized buffer state between
itself and europe a buffer state that
eventually may become if not all of it
and big parts of it
will reunifica will be in the process of
gradual reunification with russia
peter the last time that i spoke with
you on this program you were in a suit
and tie we were talking about potential
diplomatic moves things were very
different for you and for so many other
ukrainians i'm speaking to you today
you're wearing camouflage i've heard you
in various interviews talk about wanting
to uh take up the fight
from your perspective
if president zielinski were to cede to
these demands if ukraine were to declare
itself neutral how would you and how
would so many other ukrainians take that
well it's a very it's a million even a
question you know or a million ruble
question if you will uh the neutrality
idea in and of itself is not uh
necessarily a negative one for ukraine
there's the uh the much maligned term
finlandization does not necessarily have
to be so finland has turned out to be
quite well one of the most prosperous
least corrupt nations on the planet so
uh now as you mentioned there's a model
of austria being discussed sweden all of
them are good and well the question is
once you demilitarize ukraine that's the
extension of neutrality paddle just
mentioned it then what sort of security
guarantees could you rely on uh in you
know having
um the president of 1994 when the
budapest memorandum was signed uh as you
also mentioned in the lead-up to this
conversation uh and russia
clearly did not feel uh you know
beholden to it since 2014
uh it's it's been this long kind of uh
one long period of aggression against
ukraine uh so there is one uh
element to consider the second element
of this is
whether vladimir putin
has the mandate to
promise uh vladimir putin anything such
as signing off on the russian
sovereignty over crimea and eastern
ukraine putin knows this and that's why
he's sort of trying to box ukrainians
into the corner knowing that the street
the maidan you know may uh
force zielinski out of power especially
now that ukraine in its fourth week has
expended so much blood and treasure
fighting off the world's second largest
army to sign off on something like this
who is very very risky for zelensky so
um uh once again you know ukraine
understands there will have to be some
sort of a formula worked out i think
it's already come pretty close to uh
acknowledging that nato will be
pretty much uh a no-go zone meaning you
know it's ready to sort of part with the
idea of ever joining nato but in the
absence of nato there has to be some
sort of iron clad security guarantee by
several parties uh turkey us have been
mentioned uh to where ukraine would feel
confident you know that it could do that
pavel um we all know how difficult it is
when a ceasefire is declared in certain
situations to ensure
that the situation on the ground can be
stabilized that's a very different kind
of matter so i want to ask you if a
ceasefire is declared if these
negotiations
get to the point where there is some
kind of a truce could the situation on
the ground be stabilized
uh at present i don't believe that's
possible it's a kind of salami situation
with ukrainians and russians intermixed
troops i mean in different parts of
ukraine there's
five russian offensives happening and
there's no straightforward
uh front line
one and kind of maintaining a ceasefire
there is virtually impossible a
ceasefire could be only if it's
immediate uh withdraw of russian troops
or ukrainians surrendering i mean it
should be fouled almost immediately by
measures to decouple the uh the fighting
people from both sides and that's right
now the problem because a russian
withdrawal says ukrainians demanding uh
uh antebellum will draw to the positions
of uh
24th of february this year which most
likely russia won't take and any kind of
russia keeping some kind of pieces that
it has already taken
that would mean that there's going to be
more fighting uh right now i don't
really see a ceasefire or an agreement
emerging both sides are talking about
wanting to have it because everyone
wants peace and no one wants to be the
bad viewer who says no peace and sorry
uh but in fact the positions of the two
sides right now are almost
incompatible i'm afraid that there's
going to be continued bloodshed for the
time being it's going to be decided
for the time being not by diplomats but
by soldiers fighting with arms in the
field andreas i just want to take a step
back for a moment and see if you could
try to walk our viewers through just how
big a geopolitical shift is happening
especially in europe right now as a
result of russia's invasion of ukraine
i think it's a fundamental shift that
goes far beyond the east european
region
um
russia is going
to be a very different actor afterwards
i think the eu is going to change nato
is going to change
um
the biggest change that i see and the
saddest
change is that to the
international regime for the prevention
of the proliferation of nuclear weapons
because the most scandalous perhaps
aspect of this entire conflict is
that
it's defined of course by
the presence of nuclear weapons on the
russian side and the absence of nuclear
weapons on the ukrainian side and the
scandal here is that
russia is does not only have nuclear
weapons it is also explicitly allowed to
have nuclear weapons by the
nuclear nonproliferation treaty
and ukraine is it does not only not have
nuclear weapons but it's also explicitly
forbidden to have nuclear weapons and
the most grotesque aspect of this is of
course that you that ukraine was for a
short period of time
in the early
1990s
the third
largest nuclear weapons state of the
world and had more nuclear ammunition
and warheads than china france and great
britain together they could not control
most of these weapons but anyway it had
a huge arsenal back then gave it away
gave it to russia and uh 20 years later
with the annexation of crimea
it was it was punished for this and this
is going to make um actors and
politicians
and experts diplomats around the world
not only in europe
or in asia but around the world think
twice about their security about the
validity of international law about how
they can protect themselves and how they
may also be able to snatch
a territory that they want to get from a
neighboring country peter despite the
repeated pleas from president zielinski
and so many other ukrainians nato has
continued to refuse imposing a no-fly
zone over ukraine do you think that at
some point that might change that
pressure would build so substantially um
from possibly even within nato member
states that there could be a shift in
that stance
many of us are attempting to speculate
on that and one has to be careful not to
be uh
to to come across as a war monger
because we all understand the
implications of the war and ozone
we understand the europeans concern the
global concern that that would lead to a
direct confrontation with the nuclear
power
uh so having said that i would say that
following the logic of this escalation
and once again serious questions about
the rationality of vladimir putin who
has spent two years in a bunker
uh hiding from kovitt and apparently now
hiding from his own officials
on possibly uh
afraid of an assassination attempt one
may wonder if he is uh still with us in
this realm and in this world rather than
the world of his own invention and so uh
you know this is a very dangerous moment
obviously no one wants to escalate any
further but at the same time there is a
understanding on the part of the of nato
and the us
that a fight for ukraine is something
larger than a fight just for ukraine's
sovereignty it's a fight for the western
credibility and legitimacy having said
that you know uh what's the next best
option the next best option is for a
nato to enable ukrainians to try to
enforce their own semblance of a no-fly
zone uh with uh air air defense systems
with anti-tank missiles and yes with uh
fighter jets something that
poland and us have come very close to
deciding on there's a snafu now i think
zelinski's speech to congress yesterday
was a very serious uh contribution to
that decision being made considering
that uh joe biden is now under pressure
from the opposition and from members of
his own party to deliver on uh the
promise to ukrainians
pavel if russia were to manage to take
keeve what exactly does that mean
does that mean that there is no more
chance for diplomacy does that mean
there's automatic regime change does
that mean negotiations continue what
happens
if that were to occur
i don't think that russia has right now
the capacity to actually
successfully take key if it's a very big
city and the russian forces that are
there uh to the north of the city are
just simply not big enough
but russia can bombard
kiev which
didn't do up to now but it can begin a
kind of siege and a bombardment
which would make life very miserable and
very dangerous in kiev
again i'm not sure that that's right now
going to happen immediately it seems
that the russian
main military
thrust is going to be to do all possible
to swiftly capture uh mariupol
and maybe put more pressure on nikolai
russia is right now running
low on reserves
so
and actually moving more forces to
uh north of kiev i mean maybe if they
had them they can't keep them there
there are very enormous logistical
problems especially with those
paratroopers that are deployed there so
i don't think if right now is on the
cards of course things may change uh if
political decisions are made in russia
but nothing uh but
a bombardment is possible uh an
effective
a swift offensive to take the city not
it's i mean it's bigger than masoo and
it would take i mean i don't know uh uh
months a year maybe to go through it and
turn it into a pile of total
rubble and then take it and liberate it
that way i don't think russia is ready
for that i don't think it has the
capacity andreas from your vantage point
is there any acceptable off-ramp than to
the conflict that can be offered to
president putin right now
i don't think that it actually
depends that much on
what is offered because my uh my
impression from the russian propaganda
machine that it can basically
provide this sort of off-ramp for
poutine
in almost any way if there's any
concession that ukraine can make
symbolic or non-symbolic that will that
could potentially be
already enough for uh for putin to
withdraw if he wants to withdraw that's
i think the
crucial question and as i said for that
the costs and risks of this entire
operation will have to raise
and
the west is the only
the only
the actor
that can raise these costs by imposing
more severe sanctions by delivering
heavier weapons
and
i agree here with peter that
maybe ukraine does not even need a
no-fly zone imposed by nato what they
just need needs is
the right material the right weapons
perhaps also volunteers
veterans war veterans or army veterans
from perhaps not only nato countries
that would come to the international
legion of um ukraine that already exists
and would then operate and
and provide the logistic support for
let's say um
anti-aircraft weapons peter we only have
about a minute left i just want to ask
you very quickly
are you hearing from fellow ukrainians
any sense of hope that the negotiations
that are going on right now might
actually yield some kind of meaningful
ceasefire or into the conflict
i i don't think the ukrainian uh
ukrainians now that i talk with are
putting any uh of their hopes in uh
diplomatic uh in a process they're
putting their hopes in the resolve that
ukrainians have shown to fight for their
country
and to fight against the enemy uh this
is as black and white as conflicts go uh
and the sort of national mobilization
i've seen and the rise of the national
spirit is unlike anything ukraine has
known since the 1940s since world war ii
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thank you so much to
all of our guests peter zelmay pavel
felgenhauer and andreas umland
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
mohammed jim joham and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]